we've got a story about some relics that
just unearthed in the uk
newsweek reports a mom and daughter in
lincolnshire were picking up the litter
at a local river when they found a
message in a bottle two messages
actually
from teens jennifer and janet who were
looking for boyfriends back in the
summer of
1966.
wow their notes are fully intact janet
wrote i'm 15 not bad looking long wavy
brown chestnut hair and five foot four
so they made uh the first old dating app
rossi if you think about it i guess i
guess that's cute yeah okay i
okay it's cute
i don't know i it's so romantic putting
a message in the bottle and it's
littering
right it's littering
through that bottle into the ocean well
um i think it's cute though and we
actually looked into this story and one
of the women they tracked down and it
turns out she found love what yes she's
married not because of the bottle just
like in life
it worked out and i love that people put
out into the world what they want you
know she's she she did that and and
we've talked about you online dating you
you are on it you're off it sometimes
what about this you want to kick it old
school because i have a bottle right
here i can
i can write down if you want to
you want to write or you want me to i
want you to write it because i feel like
going through your energy okay like
we're doubling down on the goodness
hello
i'm drew
[Applause]
i'm what do you want to say about
yourself
um
i'm
someone in the audience said stunning
that's a good move
can i write it
i love you
and what's your name
nicole i'm putting you in the note
nicole sad
hard-working
[Applause]
my glasses fogged up
[Applause]
i wrote
i wrote hello i'm drew i'm stunning
according to nicole she also said i'm
hard-working and capable nicole talks
too fast
by the way recycle okay and i'm gonna
put this
in your
bottle all done
can i give this to her
here also here i just wrote this little
love note for you
i heart nicole
love true
here you go oh my gosh thank you you're
welcome
[Applause]
thank you you're happy
good job oh
i was not expecting that nicole
i wasn't expecting this either but i'm
so happy thank you thank you
wow god okay well
next up cnn reports that music icon
dolly parton says that there's only one
person that she would want to play her
in a movie and it's none other than tony
award-winning broadway powerhouse
kristen chenoweth such a
so much brilliant she says kristen is
absolutely fantastic and if there's ever
a biopic she would be her first choice i
mean rossi
it's a no-brainer but i can
[Applause]
why am i going parliament and you're
going dolly parton i look like i i'm a
judge in a british
show
give me a gavel what is going on i don't
know but i am feeling myself in this
side
of the bed stumble in the kitchen
look at me pour myself a cup of ambition
watch out
kristen chenoweth i'm coming for your
gig and i am going to change legislation
[Music]